let's get expert reaction out of my
exclusive interview with Carter Paige
joining us in studio got all three of
them Republican congressman Ron De
Santis Fox News contributor Washington
Examiner reporter Byron York and Fox
News contributor senior editor at the
Federalist Molly Hemingway
Byron let's start with you reaction well
sometimes it's hard to actually get all
the facts out of Carter page because he
just doesn't speak all that directly but
that point where he said I've talked
about this extensively with both houses
of Congress which is true I mean if you
read the interview that he had with the
House Intelligence Committee it just
went on and on and on and on I thought
the most telling part of your
questioning was about him saying that
touting himself as an adviser to the
Kremlin why would you do that I think
most people theorize and we're just
theorizing that he was just trying to
make himself look more like more of an
insider than he was that never happens
in Washington or never people inflate
their resumés or Molly well so he was a
businessman based in Russia for a long
time that's where he's done his life's
work he does have contacts with Russia
that is actually not a crime to have
these things and so just being seeing
him and seeing him talk about some of
these things that's very interesting
he's a man who has had all the power of
the federal government going up against
him they're surveilling him and and and
also this has very much affected his
life and his reputation his business
relationships I think it's time for the
federal government if they think he's
guilty of something they need to put up
or shut up and let this man attempt to
reclaim his life they have not told him
he's a target of the investigation Ron
your reaction to what he said tonight
well I mean he is kind of a weird dude
but like the fact that he says release
all the FISA stuff release it that means
I'm worried about that I mean so to me
well it just seems like he wants all
this stuff to come out because he
doesn't think there's any there there
but remember because he was a US citizen
when they went to surveil him it's not
just that they're suspicions he could be
acting as an agent of foreign power you
also have to show he's violating a
criminal statute and we'd the men Nunez
memo doesn't say what statute did they
cite as a potential violation was it
just some pretextual thing or was there
honestly something where they thought he
was violating law we need to release all
of this information I
yes I felt I mean just as a human
reaction I feel sorry for Carter Paige I
mean I know he was in Russia doing I
mean I lived in Russia as a student my
guy I know a lot of people doing
business in Russia their commercial real
estate people in science and so forth
just because you've done business in
Russia and you know people doesn't mean
you're a Russian spy but most people
like they hear Carter vo he was a
Russian spy people just think that
because of the way the fake media has
reported I've heard him referred to on
network television as a known Russian
agent a known Russian agent this is the
stuff that drives me crazy but you
raised a really interesting idea about
what is his status with the mahler
investigation because he is one of if
there is collusion now he's a really
important part of this Papadopoulos was
the other person who's very important
with this he was not charged with any
crime relating to a conspiracy he simply
was charged with lying to the FBI and
now what's the deal with Carter page he
hasn't been charged with anything
are they contemplating charging him with
anything and if they don't where is the
collusion Molly this is what the federal
government can do and this is again in
my angle I did before he came on
liberals used to care about civil
liberties I mean those comments from
from Blumenthal is it finds a court the
abuses of the FISA Court you don't know
what they're doing they can spy on
Americans and here we have that happen
starting in October after he left the
Trump campaign well this is foundational
to our understanding of what it means to
be American that the federal government
cannot deprive you of life liberty
property they can't arrest you or spy on
you without a really good reason and if
the civil rights and civil liberties of
Carter page can be violated they can be
violated for anyone and that's why it's
very important that we can trust these
courts particularly because the the
target of the investigation doesn't get
the chance to make plead his own case so
we rely on the government to make sure
that they provide all the information
that this key we should point out that
the warrant it's often pointed out that
well they didn't put the warrant on him
until after he left the campaign but
that not only gets his phone calls going
forward it gets all of his email going
backward back when he was in the
campaign plus it allows the FBI to break
into his home search it and plant
electronics when he is not there in
potentially other locations I mean if
they identify other locations they could
have served
their place I'm saying it's ironic we're
talking about Russia when we do this in
the United States of American Russia
Russia Russia what are we doing to our
own people I want you to react
congressmen to both trey gowdy
and it was trey Gowdy and who else
yeah Nunez of course made the comment
today about the footnote and reacting to
it let's watch a footnote saying that
something might be political is a far
cry from letting the American people
know that the Democrats in the Hillary
campaign paid for dirt that the FBI then
used to get a warrant on an American
citizen to spy on another campaign I
read the footnote I know exactly what
the footnote says it took longer to
explain it the way they did then if they
just come right out and said Hillary
Clinton for America and DNC paid for it
but they didn't do that Ron is there
anything that can be done to the people
responsible for filing that omitting a
material fact because it was omitted in
that look I mean there were your bar
license if you're practicing law I mean
that that goes into that
look there could be criminal liability
would depend on the intent and that's
why we need all this information but
that footnote I read it I read the shift
memo it is the most circuitous way to
say that there may potentially I mean
they do they could have come out and
said it the way they did it was not
enough candor for the court it's a
material fact you omitted a material
fact from the application if I were that
FISA judge I would be livid because it
makes it makes the judge make the wrong
or potentially the wrong decision it's
the key question should the FBI be lured
into surveilling a political opponent
using opposition research bought and
paid for it by the opposing campaign
that's the key China would do it Russia
would do it could North Korea would do
it Cuba would do it and apparently we
can do that in the United States in the
know it was very very clear it says they
didn't tell them that the DNC and the
Clinton campaign was paying for it and
they did a hundred percent true even the
Schiff memo will not dispute that and
we're gonna be looking for the State
Department shoot a drop perhaps on this
I know you've been writing about it
Molly you've been talking about it thank
you all great stuff guys